pues hacer unos cuantos ejemplos más no
nos va a hacer nada de daño al contrario
entonces vamos a averiguar cuánto vale
25 entre 9 elevado a la potencia un
medio ok esto es equivalente a decir que
estamos buscando la raíz cuadrada de 25
entre 9 así es que estamos buscando un
número que si lo multiplicamos por sí
mismo dos veces lo que obtenemos es 25
novenos ahora pues 5 por 5 nos da 25 y 3
por 3 nos da 9 entonces pues porque no
intentamos ver sí
cinco tercios ese es el número que
estamos buscando y bueno vemos por aquí
que cinco tercios por cinco tercios aquí
lo que tenemos es 5 por 5 eso es 25 y 3
por 3 es 9
entonces si si elevamos 25 novenos a la
un medio lo que obtenemos es cinco
tercios que hay otra forma de pensar en
esta multiplicación es decir que estamos
elevando cinco tercios
al cuadrado ahora vamos a poner unos
números un poquito más complicados por
ejemplo 81 entre 256 elevado a la
potencia menos un cuarto ok voy a
suponer que ya le pusiste pausa el vídeo
y que ya lo intentaste y tal vez ya te
salió el resultado pero bueno lo primero
que haría yo para encontrar este número
sería deshacerme de este símbolo de
menos y que es lo que estos símbolos de
menos en el exponente hacen pues lo que
hacen es que tomemos el recíproco de
este número y que es lo que es el
recíproco pues es simplemente 1 entre el
número ahora 1 entre una fracción es
equivalente a tomar la fracción y
voltearla así es que esto es exactamente
igual
256 entre 81 elevado a la 14 así es que
aquí lo que estamos buscando es un
número que si lo multiplicamos por sí
mismo cuatro veces lo que nos da es 256
y otro número que si lo multiplicamos
por sí mismo 4 veces nos da 81 aunque
hay un número que ese número por ese
número por ese número por ese número nos
dé 81 y eso es igual lo vamos a ver con
todo el detalle del mundo cuando veamos
las propiedades de los exponentes pero
eso es exactamente igual a tomar 256 y
elevarlo a la un cuarto y tomar 91 y
elevarlo a un cuarto
esto de aquí es igual a esta fracción lo
vimos cuando estábamos resolviendo este
ejemplo aquí tenemos que 5 es la raíz de
25 y 3 es la raíz cuadrada de 9 o sea
que 5 es igual a 25 elevado a la 1 medio
y 3 también es 9 elevado a la un medio
porque entonces lo que tenemos que hacer
ahorita es encontrar estos números que
tenemos que 81 nos puede saltar a la
vista como a ver 81 es igual a 9 por 9
pero a su vez cada uno de estos 9 es
igual a 3 por 3 entonces tenemos 3 por 3
por 3 por 3 y ya ya encontramos un
número que si lo multiplicamos por sí
mismo 4 veces nos da 81 o sea que
estamos elevando el 3 a la cuarta
potencia así es que 81 es 3 a la 4 y eso
lo que implica es que 81 elevado a la un
cuarto es igual a 3
bueno pero ahora tenemos que encontrar
y resulta que 256 es igual a 4 por 4 x 4
por 4 y bueno de hecho podemos
multiplicar aquí por un 1 porque no nos
afecta en nada y el caso es que esto es
igual a 4 a la 4
así es que 256 elevado a la potencia un
cuarto es igual a 4
sí porque 4 es es el número que si lo
multiplicamos por sí mismo 4 veces nos
da 256 así es que esta fracción de aquí
es igual a haber el 256 elevado a la 14
es esto que encontramos aquí que es 44 y
81 elevado a la 14 es esto que
encontramos aquí que es 3
entonces 81 entre 256 elevado en la
potencia menos un cuarto es cuatro
tercios